you
everyone is cherry I'm on Ches calm and
I just got paired up playing a five-o
game
all right Sicilian on board let's try
Bishop to b5 line up
and castles 86 or not
okay I like being able to preserve my
bishop now on a six so that's why I
played Ricky one first I got that square
for my Bishop and we're shooting now for
d4 no reason to hold off on it I don't
worry about a pin now that the night is
here and let's expand a little bit on
the Queen side maybe clamp down in this
structure okay so now what I could close
it up with d5 but I would prefer to hold
off on that until there should be seven
is played okay and so maybe no we could
shoot for d5 what is the way forward if
I don't go with this if I play a slower
move like a flight square at this point
I believe maybe d5
okay well
do you five something else to improve my
odds hang on for a second h3 now I don't
think I could hold this yeah I'm going
to go we'll grab some space
five it is playing very quick so my
night needs to do something else so what
is that something else going to be
you find like d3
first thought was this
uh
yeah
I can also go with b3 yeah let's let's
hold off on my knight move let's get my
dark score Bishop playing
Bishop to b2
Knight to c4 maybe clean here yeah I
guess we're going to go here maybe one
day there's a sacrifice on d5 Knight c4
and then take two Center pawns out for
the minor piece it's maybe an ID on that
five I could take and on pawn takes I
could take on e5 Knight would be
unprotected I'm G takes so I'm leaning
towards a piece a curve I don't know how
good it is
hmmm let's just start start with this
pressure on a lot of stuff huh f5 on the
way the yeah
try to hold my Center maybe with Knight
to d2 but let's look at some forward
stuff I don't think the sacrifice is
working because I don't end up with a
pawn duo they're undermining my center
hmm ah this is tough tough tough tough
maybe Bishop here and a chop I'm going
to try for this
take with the night
Kahn takes on this I could look to
activate my LightSquared Bishop he's my
worst bishop
oh it's black and I come up with here
pretty interesting maneuver to Fein
kettle tonight free up the up on Knight
to f6 might be an idea yeah I guess I
have to go for this
it's a bit scary for sure yeah four
squared the e3 square Knight h5 pawn
takes pawn takes Knight g4 well I have
that covered by my queen but I was also
thinking
a quick capture would open up the f3
square for my d2 night which is a may be
my worst worst minor piece definitely
the the knight who is not as well placed
yeah the war the worse the worse of the
two nights under three for my opponent
what could I do to improve I guess queen
de to look to see one but maybe let's
still keep my eye open for some trick on
the e5 square mm here's maybe another
idea g3 Bishop h3 to activate my bishop
maybe they're considering d5
diagonal has opened up um ooh and just
as I say that here comes b5
okay well I don't think I want to have
the a file open up just yet
keep this tension clean b6 I guess I
have to throw my king in the corner and
have four I'm going to be running to see
to don't have a don't have many options
yeah let's get there
and I'm running to the corner a little
bit scary
so Queen - II - I don't even know how I
challenged that Queen she is tough I
don't know I get at that base point
either you're really gunning for some
sacrifice hero it's my opponent shooting
for Bishop to h4 and maybe who this is
tough
I'm going to go here I think they have
something fancy like this in a night
jumping into g3 pawn takes Queen h4
can I really avoid that
mmm-hmm hang on for a moment I even even
night here right now ooh
that move
oh boy really going right after my
throat here
and I think I'm getting made
the Queen returning here and then going
to h4
I don't know what I could do about that
I'm getting squeezed
who
you
okay let's just make a move I don't know
how to do about Queen returning home and
then going into a H for my dark squares
are dead I can't even control the g3
square after when I clean then the
bishop the knight to F one minute five
but I think I'm just getting mated it
also sacrifice here night to g3 Queen h4
ideas let's see if they come up with
there under the 52nd mark it feels like
there's a forced mate these three pieces
yeah
spam oh okay let's go here on the Queen
just trying to do
like to clean up the bishop is that a
mistake I think it's a mistake
arriving on H for the night skill just
jump in here got a tick
well I'm on the Queen
you
I got to take the bishop
I should have blocked with the night
to be in pre-move mode
yeah I gotta go for time burner stuff
no time ugly finish I don't know what to
think of that I felt like it was just uh
oh I felt like I was getting made it I
think I was getting mated Bishop to have
to maybe something other than Bishop to
have to I didn't have to sack my queen
like that I could have played Knight to
e3
time burning mode right there at the end
ugly ugly ugly finish but oh wow
up with something different right around
here maybe I could even hold off on a
four I'm never going to get in a five
anyhow so is it worth the weaknesses
that are created
if a four is going to be met with b6
maybe I could hold off on that because I
don't think I would have to fear let's
say B five here B five can be met with a
four and then something has to uh well
you'd have to have rook to b8 or b4
I don't know I guess we kind of go both
ways with that
I think it could be so bad playing any
four here okay let me fire up the engine
and see what
different kind of middle gameplan I
could come up with because that
that was that felt busted for sure
already what kind of different middle
gameplan could I come up with here what
is an improvement
so this is fine up to this point I know
it's a fan of d5 straightaway
ooh okay now
jumps over to a for yeah I feel that
this attention should be maintained
until the bishop makes a commitment so
first a for b6 and now
d5 but even here I wanted to hold off on
d5
what's a difference let's see maybe
maybe instead of committing my knight to
d2 the idea can be d5 c4 Knight c3
but we're then going to be transitioning
towards the king-size the thing with the
queenside being locked up with this kind
of stuff and
Bishop would prefer to be on this
diagonal when that happens so I really
do want to hold off on playing d5
but uh hey
she takes d4 and my pieces are a little
bit clumsy aren't they're not getting in
my bishop sweat
well so let's just run with this
advanced to try to get a feel for
suggesting d7 or Bishop to b7 and now
even going for route to e8 but wouldn't
the idea here be to try and get in f5
like I don't know could the night just
get out of the way real quick and then
shoot for f5 what would I be doing in
this
see four and then let's just say f5 is
in that straight away
I guess there's not enough support for
this advance um my pieces are falling on
good squares I could not get fight for
the e4 square pretty quick yeah I like
both of my Knights
who maybe uh instead of having my pieces
step on one another's toes here with 92d
five is okay but I just always had in my
mind that should hold off to maintain
the tension until the bishop makes this
commitment of the diagonal but others
some value in though going with the d5
straight away
t5c for and then find a perfect square
for the queen knight on c3
okay it's noted
so that is something different I could
go for when I was d5 now
and they went for this interesting
maneuver in fact look at the suggestion
now the Knight wants to return home just
to get into c3 yeah
okay I didn't go for that
I just want to see did black have a
mating attack here
because this is this is tough now this
is this is tough to play for white
because look at the evaluation normally
would be a bit more of an advantage
having this defy upon a computer be
weighing that a bit more but not so much
just about point two for white and this
is probably where it gets really tricky
hmm okay my Center is coming under some
fire I mean I'm probably losing right
around here let's see
check King in the corner it's not losing
yet is it ever losing yeah already right
now in Knight to g3
probably need some more time to crunch
the numbers it's a fan of Knight to g3
this pawn is a monster chop-chop and now
even these ideas
that's why I spent so much time at one
point in the game I thought I was
getting mated when I could capture the
Queen I was forgetting I could take the
clean and there's this rook move but I
would have Queen takes bishop oops
okay so the
jump in there and then that's the
follow-up night g3 default with Knight
to h5 that's pretty slick I was thinking
this and then well the bishop is in the
way for that maneuver
proved night g3 with the knight h5 to
follow that's pretty interesting
because as soon as I take here this is
now whole capture on g3 I'm no longer
controlling Jeet sorry I just occupy
okay well that would have been a pretty
big shock to see that move didn't going
for that Bishop h4 instead
now night to g3 whoo I have to take I am
in a fork and then Bishop takes g3 and I
don't know how I'm preventing this Queen
to d1 and after prepared to move my
bishop and this is just gone I do the
suggestion Bishop f2 not even letting my
king escape
here and now Knight to h5
this is a killer these dark squares are
gone and my dark square bishop is a long
way out from helping out defend any of
my kingside dark squares okay
they had their their chances here
they're killer shots with the knight
jumping into g3 and I guess I'm winning
now with Knight to c4 Knight in there I
could take and yeah my reply here took
forever I was somehow convinced that I
was getting mated with this idea even if
I took the Queen but that's not the case
because I'd rook here I could take the
bishop I must take the bishop I saw that
a bit too late so yeah and now I could
run away with g3 or King h2 it's
suggesting and then from here we're just
playing like crazy time burning moves is
it always winning okay until these last
few moves whew definitely dodged a
bullet with out when there's three or
more pieces converging on a certain
square there's usually some kind of a
tactical opportunity and that g3 square
was one that you know a lot of the black
pieces were focused on is going back to
this position pawn on f4 on f4 night on
hh5 Bishop on f2
something's happening right here this
should certainly capture one's attention
g3 square
anyhow feel free has usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below hope you're having a great
day and I will catch you soon that's all
for now take care bye
you